luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and as you guys know
we love to go camping and when we camp
we like to eat
well so i'm going to share with you a
bunch of my favorite
camping recipes some of these are pretty
fancy some of them are pretty simple
all of them are delicious so without
further ado let me show you my favorite
camping recipes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
look at that sloppy cheesy steak
sandwich right there
oh that's gorgeous oh
oh that's so good
oh
uh there we go
eggs benedict
eggs benedict is a decadent camping
breakfast item
but if you really think about it it's
all ingredients and equipment
you probably bring anyways so for a
little extra effort you can go from
scrambled eggs and bacon
to this oh it's good
and i've got some olive oil i've got
some bread flour
i've got salt and pepper a little bit of
honey
some butter
i'm gonna add some oil i'm gonna add a
pinch of salt just gonna add some butter
into the
dough
we're gonna make a very basic flatbread
and cook it on this rock over here
and you don't want to add too much water
you want it so that the dough doesn't
stick to your hands
because if it sticks to your hands it'll
stick to the rock
get that butter melting on here you know
put some honey
yeah here try it it's really hot
yummy it's really yummy
that's good yeah the honey mix
it
little trick for melting snow you got to
put a little water in the bottom of the
pan or you'll melt your pot
there it doesn't take much but
[Music]
[Music]
so
the brownies are almost done so we're
gonna get some ice cream to go with our
brownies
just take some of the fluffy new snow
here
just a little dab of vanilla
and sweetened condensed milk
and it should be cold you don't want to
melt your snow
if it's really cold and dry snow it
works a little better this is kind of
wet stuff
there we go vanilla ice cream
that tastes good tastes like real ice
cream
there we go steamed brownie when you
steam a brownie it comes out just like
it was baked
only it's more moist it's really nice
you know what this brownie needs some
ice cream
oh you don't want any of this nathan it
doesn't taste very good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
stabilizer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happens every time
[Music]
well i prepared three different types of
kebabs for dinner today i've got
bacon wrapped chicken i've got chicken
mixed with peppers and squash
and mushrooms and onions
and i've got pineapple and chicken
chunks mixed together
you can prepare these things in advance
and they're so easy and quick to cook up
great campfire food check this out
all right got the shish kebabs in these
bags here we're gonna add some barbecue
sauce to the bags
let that get all coated all over
oh yeah
oh that's looking good
got my tin can cooking pot make sure
it's bone dry
and we're gonna add peanut oil to it
so we're just going to use these little
dinner biscuits that come in the can
doesn't really matter which brand take
them with your grubby dirty camping
hands
make a little ring out of it all right
let's test the oil and see where we're
at
all right there we go that is a
beautiful donut
well it's still hot a little oily dump
it into a bag
of powdered sugar
that is a very delicious campfire donut
right there you want to use my stick
and these things are hot they just taste
absolutely delicious just like a
homemade donut
but once they cool down they kind of
taste like a biscuit so this is a food
enjoyed fresh and hot so what i have
here is
corn dog batter it's really simple to
make this is actually the recipe based
off of
the famous corn dogs at disneyland it's
basically one part
cornmeal one flour a couple teaspoons of
baking soda honey and sugar
and a touch of salt it's kind of a sweet
batter
stick a hot dog on a stick
okay i'm gonna try making it no
oh look at that
look at that is that not a gorgeous corn
dog
all right we'll just let it sit there
and cool for a little bit
my hot dog just give it a bite right
there on the corner with
um i kind of like it yeah you kind of
like that
[Music]
oh
[Music]
just put some uh water on my hands and
take the popcorn mush it into a ball and
there we go
popcorn balls who wants one there you go
mama you want one it's basically just
rice krispie treats with popcorn instead
of rice krispies
you got this little jar with butter
rosemary and a little bit of garlic and
we're gonna put this by the fire let it
get all melty and warm
we're grilling king crab legs over an
open fire
look at these beasts look at this
this is just one claw
frozen king crab legs are sold
pre-cooked so all you got to do is
basically just heat them up
and enjoy them oh man they smell so good
i can see the juices dripping out of
that one
look at that
oh this one little joint has more meat
in it than an entire blue crab
look at the size of the chunk of meat
that came out of there
holy mackerel this one's gonna get messy
folks
real messy
all right a little butter on that
whoa oh that's so good
is that cinnamon raisin brioche loaf
it's kind of like a cinnamon roll
without the frosting
the eggs are kind of frozen that's icing
the eggs
they're so frozen it's like an egg
[Music]
slushy
here guys you want some french toast
yeah do you guys like that is that good
no that's enough all right guys we are
going to make bugogi
pork fajitas bulgogi sauce is a sweet
marinade used on pork meat in korea and
it is wonderful you can find this in
most
korean and asian supermarkets and you
can even find it online
through places like amazon.com now
bugogi
goes with pork and colby marinade goes
with beef
both can be used they both work really
good in this recipe
and as with a lot of these campfire
recipes you can save yourself a lot of
time and stress
by doing your chopping and dicing at
home
now in a lot of places you can buy the
meat already cut up and marinated
but in this situation we've got some
beautiful pork loin that we're going to
cut up and marinate ourselves
my feet
all right everything we need for bugogi
fajitas let's go camping
[Music]
yeah that's already froze little boo
boogie sauce on everything
that's going to be there i've got an
idea
there we go korean bubogia pork fajitas
oh that's good
they're kind of sweet instead of spicy
really really good best korean fajitas
you've ever had
look at that we've got crabs
that one's by look at that look at that
oh what is that that is
oh that's a muscle that's a big one too
yeah you can eat these i know
really for eating is what yours
all right got olvera
here
oh my that is looking good right there
oh yeah that is all good
oh there's a big piece of crab right
there
look at that like that
delicious now for marinating the chicken
you can make your own marinade from
scratch and i did a video on how to do
that i'll put a link in the description
or you can just buy pre-made peruvian
rotisserie chicken marinade now what i'm
doing
here is i'm spat caulking the chicken
i'm taking the spine out
okay and then you just cut on either
side
of the breastbone right there the bird
will now lay flat
look at that if you ever want to cook a
whole chicken on a grill
or over a campfire spat caulking it so
it lays flat
will make it cook much more evenly
thoroughly and quickly we're going to
take the skin
and pull it up a little bit dip your
fingers in the marinade
chop it up and cook it in quarters
teeny tiny they are like death
all right we're all ready for our
campout
[Applause]
uh
there you go we got some green sauce on
the side it smells amazing
there you go
on the shrimp
there we go pretty white catfish
blaze
blackened redfish magic here and get
this pan
hot once the butter turns brown
lay those fillets in there
to take this leftover rice from last
night
and let that soak up all the butter and
seasonings and grease
blackened catfish and rice there you go
crispy blackened catfish with fried rice
go heavy now let's go get a frying pan
really hot
time to fry yeah
okay
oh hold it you got it you got it hold it
strong all right
blackened catfish with pico de gallo and
avocado
what do you think of the catfish nathan
i like it
yeah we got it with some green chili
sausage
cutting up the vegetables is 90 of the
work once we get out there and start
camping
it'll be so easy to make a delicious
japanese curry that'll feed
a ton of people
start off with the stuff that takes the
longest to cook like potatoes
and then you just work your way up so go
potatoes carrots
onions beans you know mushrooms that
sort of thing
so you can use any meat you want in
curry but i think chopped up kielbasa is
the
absolute best for japanese curry
just greasy and flavorful
all right now we got all the veggies
cooked we add the curry
there we go
oh i should probably read the
instructions i burn it all right
let that sit
all right it is dinner time let's get
some curry going
all right anybody so about my bike
you like that
oh you got it buddy you got him keep
that rod up keep the rod up in the air
oh right up oh
fresh alaskan salmon is one of those
fish that's hard to screw up
hands down my favorite recipe is melted
butter
and brown sugar smothered all over a
filet and grilled
oh so good
i think
there you go a slab of fresh grilled
salmon and corn on the cob man
we got some chunk of baguettes meatballs
tater tots
canned button mushrooms you can use
all sorts of stuff in fondue now fondue
may not seem like a great camping food
but that's what it was invented for it
is a traditional
swiss camping food people would take a
thing of old cheese which keeps very
well you can just throw in your backpack
and a bottle of wine and it would go up
and they would melt up the cheese and
dip
all their leftover bread in it now the
purpose of adding the white wine
to the cheese is the acidity of the
white wine breaks down the cheese and
makes it smooth and
velvety i don't drink wine so we're
going to use lemon juice instead to get
that acidity
and we're going to use chicken stock as
our liquid like that babe
it's really good what do you think you
like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right guys we're gonna make some
seafood jambalaya here and i've got this
cajun spicy jambalaya mix i picked up in
louisiana
celery peppers onions
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
done
once the carrots start to get soft then
we add
the honey we want them bendy not mushy
all right i just pull these off the heat
and let them sit
well i hope you enjoyed this video if
you want to see more campfire cooking
videos
check out our campfire cooking video
playlist on the outdoor boys youtube
channel
thanks for watching and don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like
this and don't forget to click subscribe
so you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching